[Music]
don't shoot the messenger unless you're
an israeli soldier in that case you're
seemingly okay with shooting a reporter
who's clearly identifiable as a
journalist and poses no threat
sharing about is the latest reporter to
be killed by the israeli military which
has a long history of targeting
journalists and news outlets
particularly al jazeera
shireen a veteran reporter who spent her
life covering events in occupied
palestine was among a group of
journalists documenting what was
happening in janine early on wednesday
according to eyewitnesses and video
footage she was wearing a safety vest
and helmet both of which clearly
identified her as a member of the press
despite this or maybe because of it
shireen was shot and killed
we were going to film the israeli army
operation and suddenly they shot us
without asking us to leave or stop
filming the first bullet hit me and the
second bullet hit shireen they killed
her in cold blood because they are
killers and specialize in killing only
palestinian people so they claimed that
some palestinian militants were there we
had no resistance and there was no
palestinian military resistance at all
at the scene
journalist ali samudi was also shot and
injured in the attack
there was no exchange of fire so there
is no possibility whatsoever that a
palestinian have shot sharing
the israeli army always uses these
excuses to cover up the crimes they are
committing against palestinians
including palestinian journalists
[Music]
according to rights groups israel has
killed 50 journalists since 2000 and
injured more than 144
in the past four years alone
this is also not the first time israel
has intentionally targeted al jazeera
last year the network's office in gaza
was bombed to rubble
while journalist javar al-bideri was
assaulted by israeli forces whilst
reporting on israel's ethnic cleansing
of arab residents in occupied east
jerusalem's sheikh darrah neighborhood
israeli authorities say they've launched
an investigation but human rights groups
say they have little faith in israeli
justice particularly with renowned
organizations like human rights watch
and amnesty international accusing
israel of implementing a system of
apartheid
there are
um human rights organizations for
example like betsy lim and israeli human
rights organization
that decided a long time ago that they
are no longer going to
even interact with the complaint system
within the israeli army
because it is not serious
it doesn't find israeli soldiers guilty
qatar's foreign ministry whose country
hosts the al jazeera network issued a
statement with senior diplomats
lululhator demanding an end to what she
called state-sponsored israeli terrorism
the european union and other members of
the international community have also
condemned the killing but all these
condemnations have fallen short of
including any sanctioning or punishment
for a crime that threatens the essence
of any free society a free press
sharing was killed trying to inform the
world of what was happening in her
country the world now knows that in
occupied palestine no one is safe from
israel's bullets not even journalists
veteran journalist shireen abu akla's
body has just arrived outside al
jazeera's headquarters in ramallah you
can actually hear the crowd cheering and
clapping
there looks to be
thousands of people who have turned out
to pay their respects her body had
traveled from janine to nablus and it's
now in ramallah nida ibrahim is there
for us
in the occupied west bank nida describe
the scenes there in the sense of
emotion we're
seeing shireen's colleagues some of
those who were with her when she was
shot in the morning arriving now
as
we also can see from the picture now the
body
is being taken out of the ambulance
to
enter here
at this
small room
the ground floor open to zero surfaces
colleagues
friends
family
loved ones
to
very
difficult situations
[Music]
slogan
i'm just going to interrupt you there
because it's quite difficult to hear you
what we're going to do is we're just
going to listen in now because we're
just going to watch what's happening so
just stay with us neither but we just
want to watch and hear what's happening
now
[Music]
for those of you just joining us i'll
just let you know what we're witnessing
at the moment shireen abu akhla's body
has just arrived at the al jazeera
headquarters in ramallah let's watch and
listen
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
those of you just tuning in shireen abu
akla's body has just arrived in ramallah
and been carried inside the al jazeera
headquarters they're hugely emotional
scenes here as colleagues friends
civilians watch on
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
foreign
okay we are seeing live pictures coming
out of ramallah now of college friends
strangers paying their respects to
shireen abu akhla
her body has been transported from
janine to nablus and it's now in
ramallah let's just listen a little
further
[Applause]
[Music]
is
we're just going to get a look at the
scene outside the offices i mean the
scenes and it's an ocean of a crowd more
or less it looks like there are
thousands of people who have turned out
to pay their respects and to say goodbye
to this beloved journalist shireen abu
akla she was 51 years old she's a
household name a veteran journalist who
was shot and killed in the occupied west
bank
extraordinary scenes outside the offices
there as there's an outpouring of
emotion let's listen back in
[Music]
okay let's head back inside now into the
al jazeera offices where close friends
colleagues
strangers civilians
everyone there trying to pay their
respects to this
well-known household named journalist
let's have a listen
[Applause]
is
[Music]
uh
for those of you just joining us that is
the body of veteran journalist shireen
abu akla she is in ramallah outside what
was once her office the al jazeera
headquarters there there are huge scenes
huge numbers of of people there paying
their respects to this journalist uh she
her body had been in janine it traveled
to nablus where huge crowds turned out
and now it's in ramallah where thousands
of people are there to say goodbye
just extraordinary scenes let's just
have a little look now at where her body
is and what people are doing
um
[Music]
[Applause]
okay we will continue that coverage of
ramallah in just a moment but in the
meantime let's head to outside shireen's
house where stephanie decker is standing
by for us
steph the israeli police were there
earlier explain what's what's been
happening
yeah let me just uh refer back to those
images that we were just watching i was
watching them
on my phone really incredibly poignant
you had the al jazeera bureau chief
walidal ahmadi there
our colleagues all the correspondents
cameramen engineers um
which was received i believe by a priest
from what i could see there uh blessing
um but you know
to think that she laughed this morning
uh in janine pulling in telling her
colleagues i'm going to go cover the
raid and that her body has now been
brought into the ramallah bureau
on a stretcher draped in the palestinian
flag
i could see a wrath of flowers a lot a
lot of people outside our office in
ramallah paying
respects but certainly incredibly
emotional and unbelievable images
watching her body arrive there i have to
say
coming back to here we are outside the
family home you can hear
some of the youth there uh you know
saying that they're not afraid of the
israeli occupation of the army of the
intelligence you asked me about holding
hands that they're strong together
somebody's just translating for me
but you asked me about the police we had
three israeli police officers arrive
here about two hours ago entering
the family home which obviously caused a
lot of controversy here they were
followed by you know everyone here
telling them to get out of the house
basically telling the family who's
receiving mourners and condolences to
switch off the music there were speakers
that were this has done they have left
now and since then they've left
completely but certainly a move that uh
you know at a time in the family's
morning shadeen wasn't married she
doesn't have children she has a brother
he's expected to arrive later today from
africa her sister-in-law is here in the
house her niece is also expected
to arrive tomorrow um her body will be
in ramallah
where president mahmoud abbas
will be
paying his respects tomorrow and then we
expect the funeral to take place here
in beit hanina in occupied east
jerusalem on friday but certainly again
um
you know just seeing her body carried
like that into the offices and watching
our colleagues the bureau chief stand
around
sobbing incredulous it's it's just it's
it's impossible to believe i think
people everyone here were still in shock
that this has actually happened yes
steph that's what i was going to say it
must be surreal to see our colleagues
draped over her body
the emotion of of all of that i mean
what did she mean to that office and
what did she mean to the greater public
[Music]
well al jazeera and al jazeera arabic in
particular has been um you know a
pioneer really when it comes to how they
covered news when they first launched in
the arab world and their correspondents
are household names in the middle east
whether you like al jazeera or not
people watch al jazeera particularly
here um in the occupied territories they
are constantly on the story on the story
when the international media
has long moved on al jazeera arabic in
particular will always be covering
whether it's home demolitions whether
it's forced evictions whether it's being
in gaza whether it's being in the
occupied west bank and talking about
settlement expansion whether it's you
know the continued removal of land
whether it is as shadeen was doing this
morning the continued raids that the
israeli army carries out
in the occupied west bank this morning
there was
an exchange of fire between israeli army
and palestinian gunmen and she sent an
email to the office around six o'clock
in the morning talking about a raid
going on that they were getting ready
to go and cover it and again as we've
been saying all day you know these are
household faces uh she is
extremely well loved by her colleagues i
didn't know her very well uh but i
remember her as always having a sort of
kind and calm
uh demeanor to her when we did cross
each other but certainly my colleagues
in ramallah need our correspondent and
iranian besides themselves we're
extremely close to her she's incredibly
kind um and hard working uh again like
there's been tensions here for weeks on
end people have been working non-stop
for weeks covering you know escalations
back and forth she was due to go on
holiday one of my colleagues uh just
told me so
it is
it's still impossible to believe really
i mean those images just watching them
coming in uh i was watching the live
feedback on my phone uh watching you
know the bureau chief walid and i could
see like elias couple of our
correspondents there merwan crying um
i can't imagine being there and actually
seeing her being carried on you know on
a stretcher draped in the palestinian
flag
um
you know and then she is no more it is
it's it's yeah it's uh it's a shock to
all of us
steph we're going to try and cross to
anita shortly but in the meantime i just
wanted to to get your thoughts as a
journalist given what's happened to
shireen do you think that this will
deter journalists from doing their jobs
in the region or will it further
add to their resolve to tell these
stories
no i don't think this is going to stop
people from doing their jobs i think in
fact you know it it actually strengthens
uh people's desires and the need to
continue telling the story this is i
have to say unfortunately nothing really
new when it comes to palestinian
journalists they have been killed in the
past i've covered funerals in the past
in gaza in particular one palestinian
journalist who was killed during the
border protests and certainly there was
not the international spotlight on that
as there is now of course al jazeera is
a huge network qatar is an important
player this is also becoming you know
somewhat of a diplomatic uh incident
you've had the entire world react you've
just heard from the u.s ambassador to
the u.n uh refer to it you've had
countries condemn it calling for
independent investigation you've had
ambassadors to israel the u.s ambassador
the british ambassador the u.n special
envoy to the middle east peace process
all saying this needs to be investigated
i can tell you from my experience that
the response from the israeli officials
is something that is unprecedented we
heard from
the foreign minister you've heard from
the defense minister benny gatz you
heard from natalie bennis bennett the
prime minister in the knesset addressing
this directly saying that there will be
an investigation initially saying that
what the israeli
army thought was that potentially uh she
had been hit by palestinian gunmen
during an exchange of fire in janine you
now have according to one israeli
journalist with incredibly good strong
connections quoting the israeli chief of
staff saying that they can now no longer
really tell which side fired uh and that
he regrets the death and that an
investigation team has been set up
we're trying to get this confirmed by
the army but uh this journalist has
solid sources um so but palestinians
will tell you that they don't trust any
israeli investigation when it comes to
how they operate because there is a
history
of excessive force that multiple uh ngos
organizations have always uh accused of
we've seen it ourselves covering the
stories here on the ground um so what
shireen's death is highlighting is
something that
is not new unfortunately um to a certain
extent it doesn't always end in death
but certainly injury uh maiming arrests
so
as you were hearing from my colleagues
throughout the day you know also their
journals covering the story but they're
also very much covering their own story
[Applause]
steph you've covered this region for
some time now
do you think i mean looking at those
scenes that we've seen just in the last
hour or so with thousands of people
turning out
how do you think palestinians will react
in the coming days and weeks with
particular dates of significance coming
up on the 15th of may
could shireen's death be a tipping point
in this tension
[Music]
[Applause]
i i'm not going to predict that i think
you know the ground here i can tell you
one thing about this region is that if
anything can happen um what i can tell
you is that certainly
shireen her death is hugely
symbolic she's someone who's a household
name to palestinians who watch the news
and not just here but across the middle
east as someone who has continuously
covered the israeli occupation that many
people will tell you has become
normalized you even have you know many
arab countries and states making deals
with israel
so many palestinians will tell you that
they feel somewhat abandoned when it
comes to the governments of these
countries um so you know it's a it's a
situation that i think is highlighting
putting the spotlight back on uh the
continued occupation that many
palestinians say has become normalized
uh and is continuous and it's almost
like managing the occupation many people
will use that phrase
so what you see now is again a highlight
of an issue that is daily that is
ongoing perhaps not the death of
journalists but certainly
the things that evolve on the ground
palestinians will tell you there's very
little pressure when it comes to the
international community actually i was
here in 2014 which is the last time when
you had peace talks or talking about
peace jokes and you had the secretary of
state at that point in time john kerry
come here i think two or three times
during the space of a week shuttling
between ramallah
and jerusalem
at the time it was uh it was
prime minister netanyahu who was in
charge but they didn't even get close to
even scratching the surface of any
potential peace trucks that could lead
to a palestinian state which of course
what the palestinians want is along 1967
lines which is occupied as jerusalem as
its capital the occupied west bank and
gaza and with the increase also of you
know the situation at the al-aqsa mosque
compound which is another issue that's
been inflaming the ground that's been
inflaming rhetoric um
you know it's simply as palestinians
will tell you an ongoing situation that
very little international pressure
recently has been
applied to to try and change all right
steph we appreciate you breaking it all
down for us stephanie decker live for us
in the occupied east jerusalem outside
shireen's house